firefighters in siberia are battling
massive wildfires which have been
burning for weeks
and are now beginning to threaten major
cities in the region of yakutia
the blazes have been fueled for months
by extreme heat
which scientists say is a result of
climate change
russian officials are using aircraft to
fight fires
currently burning across an area of some
120 square kilometers
on the ground the situation is said to
be improving
but it's far from under control
as for today the wildfire situation
remains difficult
and we have an emergency situation in
the region
as of this morning there were 40 active
forest fires
officials have also called in hundreds
of explosive experts to make fire breaks
creating gaps in the trees and
undergrowth should contain the fires
[Applause]
officials are worried that the flames
could reach nearby cities
people in the regional capital yakutsk
have for days been doing their best to
deal with living in a city
shrouded in thick smoke
there's an unpleasant scratchy feeling
in the throat but what can we do
it's hard to breathe especially with a
mask and the weather's hot
the weather is certainly a factor with
daytime temperatures of up to 35 degrees
celsius
unusually hot for the northern russian
region